this this stuff is like exactly why i
like sometimes
really hate coding
[Music]
hello and happy tuesday it's been a long
while since i picked up the vlog camera
it's still not really a part of like my
daily
routine or even weekly routine to vlog
and stuff
but it's december
8th i took the whole week off for
thanksgiving
which felt so good it was the first like
vacation that i've had
since i started this whole youtube thing
and for like the last
month before that i was working weekends
too do not overwork fam this is not a
psa to
overwork yourself until you need the
break so desperately that even when you
take the break you can't rest because
that's not cool it took me like three or
four days to even like fully like
enjoy and start to relax
so yeah it was uh really important that
i took that break
i realized just how much more i needed
to be taking breaks
luckily this week for me finally is like
a little bit more chill
i have therapy in about 30 minutes but i
wanted to show you some of the things
that i worked on
during thanksgiving because i'm pretty
proud of all this stuff
and my diy skills are really coming
together
and so i wanted to show you the first
thing that i made was
that bench seat so my office room that's
my desk right there
has like this whole bench area and
originally i was going to get like a
custom felt cushion
but i had some of this upholstery left
over
from when i upholstered my dining chairs
and so i decided to get some foam
and do it so now it's kona's favorite
seat
let me show you how it works underneath
excuse me sir excuse me
i gotta show people how this works can
you get off so yeah this is what it
looks like
underneath basically there's three
boards here i connected it together
with some pocket hole screws there's
something called batting which is like
another cushioning
in between the upholstery material and
the felt
and then i just stapled it all together
it's a little crude
but i think it looks really good on top
and it's quite comfortable to sit in
would you say so kona is that your
favorite seat you can go back there now
i'm sorry i kicked you off
i also have this like christmas light
set up here
in my room next is my biggest build
which i'm very
excited to show you ta-da i made a
dining table
out of wood there's a bunch of stuff on
top so
don't mind that but i got a bunch of
wood from home depot
and i used wood glue and wood screws to
put it all together
i made this to use for our outdoor area
i was gonna get like patio furniture but
i was like i could just like
make one and make it the way that i like
in a design that i like
and color it how i like so found these
plans online for free
and white and i made it all by myself
i had a little bit of help from scott
but most of it was me i'm
so proud of this because like look at
how perfect look at how clean that
is countersinked and everything i am
quite proud of how it turned out uh this
isn't quite finished yet though because
i have to
sand the top and then i'm gonna stain it
with that stuff
and seal it so that it can sit outside
and take on the outdoors
ellie you want to say hi to everybody
oh why not oh hello
ellie has also been adjusting to this
house
and us quite swimmingly she's doing
great
she's so smart yeah it was really fun to
work on the diy projects i frankly wish
that i had more time off
to work on them i'm gonna also build
benches for that table
and then i was also gonna build a
entryway table that
[Music]
excuse me what are you doing
what do you do you're just digging at
the hats
anyway it's really satisfying to level
up my skills
and it's really fun i just like put on
music
and like using my whole body and not
just my minds to make something
i don't know i just realized that like
regardless of whether i'm working or not
i just like to make stuff and so it's
been
real fun to kind of explore that side of
myself
i also have an upcoming break taking two
weeks off for the holidays which is
going to be great
so i hope to do some more building then
oh yeah end of the year is rough
because maybe y'all are also in the same
spot but like
deadlines and finals and just all the
things that need to be done before the
end of the year
just feel like they get crammed until
the very end which is basically the spot
that i'm
in so i do a little tea time with
guess who it's boxy sponsor of today's
video
is you guessed it foxu foxu is a monthly
subscription
box that sends premium japanese snacks
right to your door
so every month there's a different theme
and they send different snacks and
candies and tea pairings on that theme
i've been sponsored by boxy for a couple
months now and each month's theme has
been
amazing i love how seasonal they are and
never get tired of the different snacks
because they're always different inside
these guys shipped straight from japan
to
many many countries out there and so
it's really convenient
to just get amazing japanese snacks that
you honestly wouldn't be able to find at
your local asian market
delivered right to your door and i
recently sent it as a gift to my friend
and it's honestly a great gift idea for
the holidays as well i really like baksu
i just i really like it it's like one of
my favorite things that i look forward
to every single month
and so i'm excited to take a peek in
this one this one's box is golden
kanagawa and so there's
tons of snacks inside
and multiple of some of them to showcase
all of the wonderful snacks from
kanagawa
japan so because you're the sponsor of
today's video you can get 10 percent off
of your very own boxy for
savings of up to 47 by using my code and
link in the description box
using that code and link specifically
helps support my channel and allows me
to do what i do
so yeah my channel is probably funded on
snacks which is great like i wouldn't
have it any other way
and now i think i'm just gonna enjoy
some tea
[Music]
so
[Music]
happy saturday beginning of our winter
break
we're starting it off in beautiful
encinitas and uh doing some trendy stuff
we're just running errands
we're at a coffee place called we're
checking it out today
and then we're also gonna go pick up
some plants
and yes
[Music]
i've never been to this coffee place
before
oh it's like it tastes very like almost
chocolatey
yeah like kind of like a mocha okay yeah
but it's espresso
it's a very dark roast but not burnt
yeah but not burnt
okay okay exploring more of san diego's
[Music]
coffee
[Music]
san diego's got an abundance of trendy
coffee stores
and trendy garden centers both of which
are some of my favorite weekend
activities and the weather is just
gorgeous i mean look at this blue sky
it's so pretty out today
so i went down like a rabbit hole last
night
um i've been trying to read books
instead of
going on my phone for hours on end
before sleeping
because when you're on social media you
can never really tell what you're gonna
get
and so instead just reading books and
slowing down
at night i realized i've been able to
sleep much better
but um i've been having a hard time
finding a new book to read
especially because just like my anxiety
is fine it's very manageable but like
just certain things are very triggering
and some plots in books are very jarring
i guess
and so i've been trying to find books
that are like not scary
not shocking at all and it's been really
hard to find those books i recently
heard of a book called convenience store
woman
online and it's like a apparently a
pretty light-hearted novel and there's
an english translation for it because
it's
originally a japanese book and so i was
gonna rent it
through my library but they didn't have
it and then i was like i should just
read it in japanese
i figured out a way to buy the ebook
on kindle through the amazon store in
japanese
and load it onto my kindle and now i can
read japanese books on my kindle
which is a way better way to read books
especially japanese ones than i've ever
had because if there's like a kanji that
i don't know then i
can look it up really easy and then i
was looking at what other books i should
buy on the japanese amazon store
and one of the books was momo by michael
endy or mikhail ende
i wanted to read it because it's a book
that was really popular in japan
but i wanted to read in english but it's
like not a really common book most
libraries don't have it if i order it
online it won't get here until after
christmas
so i went down a whole rabbit hole for
that too there's any books that y'all
recommend that are like
not scary that are not about existential
questions or life and death or
about anybody getting murdered or dying
or anybody getting diagnosed with cancer
and living with that
that would be great leave them in the
comments
boy my eyes are actually very red hello
everybody
not to alarm you with the tears nothing
bad has happened
i was uh streaming on my twitch stream
earlier and i was streaming a coding
stream for the first time
in a very long while because i haven't
done it in like two months just because
i've been so busy
i had the idea to code a discord bot a
super simple one
and so i decided to do it on stream and
i ran into just so many issues with
installing python the right version of
python
installing pip installing the discord
python library
figuring out what the heck i'm doing on
windows machines originally i was coding
on windows et cetera et cetera
and because i was having so much trouble
a lot of people were providing advice on
what to do
and some of them were genuinely very
nice about it not
many people were assured of me but a lot
of people were like just do this
do that copy paste this do that and it
was just like
you know i just i was just remembering
that like when i was working full-time
as a software engineer
getting that kind of force fed here is
what you should be doing what
are you doing kind of tone from even one
person is overwhelming
so having people in chat with 200
eyes on me with like 10 people telling
me that at once
made me feel incredibly overwhelmed and
this was all just to set up python
like i just want to make this bot and
it's super cute and super like
harmless but like installing python is
so annoying
and just getting lots of like
condescending
like messages from people like not even
really trying to help just telling me
what to do and copy paste into my
command line which like i'm not gonna do
because it's strangers on the internet
but like
not really attempting to teach me or
whatever i mean it's part of it it's
just like this is a responsibility i
have to accept as
a woman on the internet doing tech and
coding things
but like i'm a very sensitive person
and when a lot of strangers and this is
me
interpreting it this way i'm sure a lot
of people didn't like
intend for it to come off this way but
when strangers are yelling and ordering
at me
to do something it makes me feel really
bad
so i don't know and this is me like i've
done this before
i can't even imagine what it's like to
like start coding and then experience
this from the get-go
some tears were shed because i was just
so overwhelmed and i was just sad
because i was like i was really looking
forward to making this bot
really looking forward to it really
looking forward to coding with the
community too
but sometimes it's really hard to put
myself out there and
not feel very vulnerable and
aggressively pushed towards a direction
that i don't even know why i'm going
this this stuff is like exactly why i
like sometimes
really hate coding and like i don't
think anybody had bad intentions
some people did some people did they got
time down and blocked and banned and
everything but like
the way that you use words the way that
you convey
messages to people have a profound
impact on that person
sure it might help solve the coding
problem or issue at hand
but like at the end of the day people
are writing these things
people are trying to solve them so i
think it's just as important to take
care of the people who are writing it
than it is to solve
the problem and i didn't experience that
today so
it's both motivation for me to create
communities that are
warm and helpful and inviting and kind
and compassionate
but i'm also just like i just felt like
needles
and when i'm already individual doggies
what are you guys
doing
[Music]
you